[Applaus]
[Musik]
donald trump wurde 2017 präsident der
vereinigten staaten und aufgrund seiner
vielen wahlversprechen wusste jeder dass
er ganz andere vorstellungen als seine
vorgänger hatte vor allem was
internationale beziehungen angeht
america first war der slogan seiner
kampagne
vier jahre und einen machtwechsel später
es bahnt sich ein erneuter
strategiewechsel an america is back
schon wieder so ein twitter wichtiger
das ging schon bei tram nicht gut aus
aber du fragst dich ja vor allem wie ist
amerika ist beck was die beiden mit der
rückkehr amerikas wo was denn die ganze
zeit war unterschreibt denn amerika
irgendwie weg verschwunden untergetaucht
nicht wirklich aber was die
amerikanische kriegsmaschinerie und des
imperialismus angeht durchaus schon war
nämlich so würde er auch daher kam einer
der friedlichsten präsidenten den die
vereinigten staaten ihr hatten im
vergleich mit seinen vorgängern
eigentlich ein pazifist er hat keinen
neuen krieg angefangen einen
historischen frieden zwischen israel und
den arabischen ländern ausgehandelt und
die beziehungen zu nordkorea entspannt
denn wie heißt es so schön hunde die
bellen beißen nicht okay tom hat
durchaus auf twitter gewütet haben ist
um die wurst ging dann wurde diese bei
weiteren nichts so heiß gegessen wie er
sie in seinen tweets immer gekocht hat
im irak und vor allem in afghanistan
da die präsenz der us truppen bis zu dem
punkt reduziert dass er einen kompletten
abzug im jahr 2021 in erwägung zog in
bezug auf seine vielleicht größte
operation während seiner amtszeit
beschränkte er sich darauf das zu ende
zu ziehen was seit obamas sowieso
bereits in gang gesetzt hatte
seine größten militärischen aktionen
lassen sich an einer hand abzählen
die ein beispiel amerika hat gerade zum
zweiten mal us streitkräfte angegriffen
das war wir reden über ein paar
bombenangriffe auf syriens strafe
baschar al-assad einsatz von chemie war
der rest waren einmalige aktion
sogenannte chirurgische operationen die
zb als spezialeinheiten dehnen da
eskalierten al baghdadi ausgeschaltet
haben oder den tödlichen drohnenangriff
auf irans terrorfürsten soll im anni und
so weiter und so fort ja aber das war s
das waren alle kriegerischen handlungen
chance man könnte also sagen eine sehr
friedliche amtszeit vor allem im
vergleich zu seinen vorgängern obama und
vor allem george hw bush jump hat keinen
neuen krieg losgetreten
und das ist schon ein sehr krasser
gegensatz zu all den apokalyptischen
vorhersagen sondern gegner
diese haben ja keine gelegenheit
ausgelassen zu prophezeien das würde
jeden moment den dritten weltkrieg
auslösen
ganz realistisch muss man aber auch
sagen dass das us militär schon mal
bessere zeiten gesehen hat es geht
einfach nicht die energie für weitere
konflikte zu haben
[Musik]
aber bei genauem hinsehen fällt einem
auf dass chance außenpolitik mit einer
uralten doktrin gebrochen hat der
doktrin welches seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg alle internationalen aktionen
amerikas bestimmt pax americana ist ein
wichtiger begriff märkten gut denn auch
wenn die falle der usa dem wandel der
zeit unterworfen werden sei es der
kommunismus oder der islamische
fundamentalismus handelten die
amerikaner immer nach den grundsätzen
der pax americana du wirst es kaum
glauben können aber hinter so
unterschiedlichen ereignissen wie den
kriegen in korea vietnam afghanistan und
im irak einzig und alleine das konzept
der pax americana wirklich hinter jedem
krieg der usa
und wenn wir über die pax americana
sprechen sprechen auch über zahllose
militärische interventionen der usa
die doktrin ist viel kritisiert worden
und auch persifliert mit bekannten
liebsten wolle
hast du in deinem land dann glaube ich
brauchst du ein wenig mehr freiheit
daher lauten die zentralen fragen dieses
videos wie effektiv war jones
aussenpolitik und america first welche
auswirkungen hat er seinen rückzug für
gegner und verbündete der usa bedeutet
die wahl beiden es die rückkehr der pax
amerikaner schlägt jetzt die einige
befürchten das amerikanische imperium
mit beiden als imperator zurücktreten
wie rein in ein zeitalter neuer
amerikanischer flügel und kriege all
diese fragen wollen wir heute
ausführlich und differenziert
beantworten und die immer tun dies mit
einem blick in die geschichte
[Musik]
die pax americana
würdest du mir glauben wenn ich dir
verrate dass deutschland ton punkten
besitzt stellt sich schon die frage wie
soll das überhaupt möglich sein
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg hat er
deutschland ja noch nicht einmal eine
armee und dann sogar atomwaffen das
könnte das zu einer katastrophe führen
man stelle sich nur vor ein nachfolger
mertes riese das vierte reich aus fahren
sie aber erst mal einen gang runter ich
habe dir einen kleinen fallstrick
gespannt deutschland ist nämlich nicht
direkt im besitz von atombomben in der
das hinten sich diese nur auf deutschem
boden
im fall eines angriffs aus deutschland
könnte man aber entsprechend reagieren
besagt atombomben werden in einer us
militärbasis auf deutsch boden gelagert
das ist die verteidigungsstrategie der
nato das system der kollektiven
verteidigung seiner mitgliedsstaaten im
kriegsfall ein weiteres instrument
welches nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
geschaffen würde
im rahmen der pax americana seinen
anfang nahm alles nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg die usa waren eine
unschlagbare weltmacht und zugleich
wirtschaftsmacht mit fast 50 prozent des
globalen bip der dollar verdrängte den
finsterling als reservewährung
militärisch konnte keiner ihre
streitmächten das was erreichen
diese dominanz bestand für einige jahre
da sie ja auch die einzige atommacht
waren washington hatte 1944 seine
hausaufgaben gemacht eine friedliche
welt war in ihrem besten interesse aber
wie erreicht man ein subtropisches ziel
die erste priorität bestand in
interventionen den feindlichen ländern
sie sollten ihre autoritären regimes
aufgeben und sich stattdessen zu
demokratien entwickeln natürlich zu
demokratien welche die usa dann ganz
doll lieb haben die zweite priorität war
der handel man träumte einen traum von
uneingeschränkten handelsbeziehungen im
gesamten best look ein handel frei von
kommunistischen uns politischen
einflüssen im prinzip eine ganz einfache
gleichung wenn die großmächte
miteinander handeln würden sie weniger
interesse daran haben sich zu bekämpfen
dies ist eine weitere säule der pax
americana und einer friedlichen welt
wenn waren wie grenzen nicht
überschreiten werden es soldaten ton
behandeln und mit ihm die
kapitalistischen länder betraten ein
goldenes zeitalter ein zeitalter des
handels und friedens in der europäischen
union gab es seit 49 keinen krieg mehr
und dies alles ist auch der pax
americana zu verdanken wir haben in
bezug auf deutschland auch internet
video dazu gedreht aber die dürfte
genauso klar sagen mir dass man für
problemlosen handel auch ein wenig
militärischen 1 braucht ein öltanker
sollte sich ja vor saudi arabien bis zu
us küste kommen können dafür dafür aber
nicht für der flotte eines anderen
landes abgefahren oder von modernen
piraten überfallen werden während des
kalten krieges vertraten die vereinigten
staaten überzeugung dass die
gewährleistung des wahren transit der
beste weg zu frieden und wohlstand sein
würde wenn dort ist sie ist einer der
hauptgründe für die zahlreichen
militärbasen der usa ist viel ändern
die usa sind eines der wenigen länder
der welt die so agieren damit sichern
sich natürlich ihre interessen zum
beispiel die sicherheit globaler
schiffers legen aber dass die usa ein
paar militärbasen in anderen ländern
unterhält muss dass du bestimmt schon
was ich dir jedoch jetzt verraten will
wird dich vielleicht schon überraschen
wir sprechen nämlich nicht nur von zwei
dutzend basel sondern von einer
eigentlich unglaublichen zahl von zirka
800 basen wenn ich auf der ganzen welt
verteilt sind so hat pax americana die
usa und ihre verbündeten vor angriffen
geschützt und hast du dir aber
vielleicht schon häufiger die frage
gestellt wieso erlaubt ein fremdes land
überhaupt die stationierung von
us-truppen in friedenszeiten ist das
nicht ein schwerer eingriff in seine
souveränität das schlüsselwort für die
antwort auf diese frage lautet
multilateralismus
verschiedenste arten von allianzen
militärische politische wirtschaftliche
zwischen diversen ländern und in genau
dieses konzept passt die nato rein
diese umfasst zuerst die westlichen
länder und wurde nach dem fall des
eisernen vorhangs um viele
osteuropäische länder erweitert bei
näherer betrachtung bestehen jedoch fast
alle militär benutzt der usa aus dem
gleichen elementen ein ob sie das offen
zugeben oder nicht das ziel dieser
bilder ist immer dass die größte armee
der welt im verteidigungsfall den krieg
auf der richtigen seite weiter
die sache ist natürlich die us-armee und
damit das alles effizienter vonstatten
geht fordern sie von ihrem partner das
recht militärbasen auf ihrem territorium
aufzubauen
und deshalb sind atomwaffen auf
deutschem grund stationiert und die
fünfte sechste und siebte flotte der us
navy liegen in bahrain italien und japan
die siebte flotten befindet sich in
neapel und für operationen im mittelmeer
aus ihre jüngste aktion war die
bombardierung libyens im jahr 2011 im
zuge des sturzes von diktator gaddafi
und tossens begeisterung für
fotoshootings mit kindern sind fast
30.000 us soldaten an der
südkoreanischen grenze zu nordkorea
stationiert so david ist die ausmaße der
globalen us bestrebungen kennst stellt
sich jedoch die frage in die herren
trugen diese eigentlich früchte da die
pax americana ein erfolgsmodell eine axt
eine neugier kann befriedigt werden die
meiste zeit waren die usa mit ihrer
doktrin erfolgreich ein direkter beweis
dafür findet sich in der globalisierung
der höhepunkt der us-amerikaner wird
meist jenem moment vor 30 jahren
zugeschrieben als sich der
kommunistische blog auflöste angefangen
mit glasnost der players troika und mit
anschließenden fall der berliner mauer
vor den aufständen in polen schließt
nicht dem ende des warschauer pakts oder
was meist hätten die usa ihren erst
falls die sowjetunion auch ohne die pax
americana besiegen können
falls du andere meinung bist dann
schreibt uns doch mal eine kleine
theorie ganz schnell in die kommentare
wenn man bedenkt dass günter schabowski
tief und fest geschlafen hat während
sein kleiner kommunikationsfehler die im
hof zum anschluss brachte ist das schon
sehr ironisch das zk nick lipski erfuhr
erst am nächsten morgen von der lawine
die er während einer kleinen
pressekonferenz losgetreten hatte
denn da mal ist vor 30 jahren
reicht er die pax americana quasi ihren
höhepunkt es herrschte harmonie auf der
ganzen welt der globale handel konnte
sich ungebremst entfalten und die usa
hielten ihre schützende hand über den
ganzen planeten
ganze zehn jahre sollte dieses goldene
zeitalter andauern doch dann erstes
september 2001 insgesamt vier flugzeuge
wurden im us luftraum entführt und zwei
flugzeuge würden in die twin towers des
world trade center gecrasht ein weiteres
ins pentagon das herz des us-militärs
gerammt in diesem tag lernte die usa die
böse fratze des terrors wie nie zuvor
kennen es war der anfang vom ende der
pax americana osama bin laden
terrorfürst und anführer von al-kaida
war ein mann der von der cia im kampf
gegen die sowjets ausgebildet worden war
hinzu kamen zwei weitere katastrophen in
dem viele us soldaten ihr leben ließen
die kriege im irak und in afghanistan
und während deutschland und japan durch
die usa 50 jahre zuvor in produktive und
wohlhabenden team verwandelt wurden
wollte dies den am ehesten im irak und
in afghanistan partout nicht gelingen
diese gravierenden rückschläge führten
unter obama zu einem rückzug der usa aus
ihrer rolle als weltpolizist es gab
keine richtige intervention in syrien
und russland konnte erfolgreich sein
extremst demokratisches überhaupt nicht
fragwürdiges referendum in der krim
durchziehen
merkwürdigerweise sprachen damals einige
länder von einer annexion und einem
einmarsch endlich kann ich verstehen
wieso man das denken könnte die grünen
menschen waren damals doch nur als
urlauber am schwarzen meer und als
echter russische patriot hat man halt
immer seine kalaschnikow dabei als purer
zufall
obama hätte was machen können aber er
hatte sich bereits vom militärischen
teil der pax americana distanziert dafür
aber seinen fokus auf den handel gelegt
durch diese bestrebungen wurde die tipp
auf den weg gebracht ein abkommen mit
der eu und anderen ländern in amerika
asien und ozeanien
dieses abkommen hätte die größte
freihandelszone der welt geschaffen
auf lange sicht hätten alle die
nordamerikanische handel tätig annehmen
müssen gegen das titel abkommen und ab
ist jedoch in der eu und in deutschland
massive proteste vor allem deshalb weil
es intransparent in hinterzimmern der
mächtigen über die köpfe der bürger
hinweg ausgehandelt worden
obamas war also das machen opus des
handels multilateralismus
doch dann kommt und alles änderte sich
[Musik]
america first eine klare ansage denn
natürlich wird schon als präsident der
usa nicht sind ab bevor slogan wählen
und der kern von amerika förstern alle
länder der welt war eine klare nachricht
die ära des zweiten weltkrieg
forschenden amerikanischen
multilateralismus neigt sich ihrem ende
zu
und hierzu muss gesagt werden dass trump
wirklich keine leeren versprechen
gemacht hat das erste mal erwähnte er
seine neue dock ziehen im vorwahlkampf
der republikaner
er kritisiert die trans pazifische
partnerschaft kittet tipp und hat sogar
das nachts abkommen nach 25 jahren neu
verhandelt mit einem fokus auf mehr
protektionismus kommen zu glauben aber
das waren schon ein paar krasse
veränderungen die jump durchgeboxt hatte
und vielleicht hast du dir schon die
ganze zeit in der songs präsidentschaft
die fragen gestellt wieso er dem allem
eigentlich so kritisch gegenüberstand
darauf kann ich dir eine ganz einfache
antwort geben im gegensatz zu seinen
vorgängern ist er einfach nicht der
auffassung das ist im interesse der usa
ist multilaterale abkommen zu schliessen
job hat während seiner gesamten
präsidentschaft eine protektionistische
haltung vertreten oder zu wissen muss
beschreibt politik die kontrolle über
den eigenhandel zu behalten
indem man für ausländische anbieter
eintrittsbarrieren in den heimatmarkt
aufbaut daher nahe
es ist eine politik die protektion also
schutz bieten soll für heimische
anbieter auf ihrem eigenen heimatmarkt
und es war kein großes geheimnis dass
der mit den usa für freihandel mit
unfairen wettbewerb und dem potential
arbeitsplätzen und unternehmen zu
vernichten einhergeht
top war der festen überzeugung dass die
usa ihre handelsabkommen nicht mit
vielen ländern auf einmal abschließen
sollten sondern land für land denn als
die mächtigste wirtschafts und
militärmacht der welt könnten dazu am
besten die eigenen spielregeln
durchsetzen er hielt es für
selbstverständlich dass die jeweils
andere seite seine bedingungen
irgendwann akzeptieren würde dass ihr es
sich nicht leisten könnte langfristig
keinen handel mit den usa treiben zu
können und ich kann dir was spoilern
hundertprozentig richtig lag er mit
diesen gedanken nicht das hat ihn aber
nicht davon abgehalten erst mal so viele
handelsabkommen video geht auf eis zu
legen oder zu kündigen damit hätten wir
aber nur einen teil seiner außenpolitik
beleuchtet denn er hatte auch noch
andere pläne
[Musik]
er stand auch der nato sehr kritisch
gegenüber denn natürlich ist je nach
sichtweise die nato entweder ein wahrer
segen oder ein riesiges schwarzes loch
für die usa sie kann ein werkzeug
darstellen und als wichtigste verbündete
europäischen länder zu gelten
mit enormen einfluss auf wirtschaftliche
und politische ebene
es kann sich aber auch als ein fass ohne
boden erweisen und trump hat nicht
gegeizt mit kritischen äußerungen europa
muss es einen gerechten anteil für den
militärischen schutz zahlen die
europäische union hat was viele jahre
lang beim handel ausgenutzt und dann
halten sie sich nicht an ihre
militärische verpflichtung im rahmen der
nato
die dinge müssen sich schnell ändern
aber auch im nahen osten veränderten die
usa den fokus ihrer außenpolitik
das credo war sehr simpel er delegierte
alle verantwortung an die saudis die
vereinigten arabischen emirate und
israel und zog sich großflächig zurück
wo von obama immer nur schwer trainiert
hatte das programm konsequent durch
worum es letztlich geht man will sich
militärisch nicht mehr die finger
verbrennen gleichzeitig aber auch nicht
sein einfluss verlieren dazu braucht man
unbedingt verlässlicher partner denen
man umgekehrt auch die treue halten muss
und niemand ist eben ein besserer
partner als saudi arabien und israel
deswegen hatte trump des audis auch mit
seinem allerersten staatsbesuch gleich
nach seinem amtsantritt
dort hat er sogar auch einen kleinen
tanz mit dem schwert aufgeführt eine
deutliche geste die um die welt gingen
es ist aber nicht nur bei einer show
geblieben trump hat noch mit zwei
weiteren weitaus größeren gesten den
saudis seine ehre erwiesen
die erste bestand darin die beziehungen
zum iran stark abzukühlen und aus obamas
vermurksten atom abkommen auszusteigen
der nächste war ein 100 milliarden
schwerer waffen will ja und dann war da
noch eine weitere sache eine etwas
schmutziger trump behauptet angeblich er
schütze saudi grund prinz nach dem car
show hot
ich habe so eine art gerettet im
neuesten buch von bob woodward zufolge
war trump bereit über den karton
gemauert hinwegzusehen solange die
saudis weiterhin ihre rechnungen
bezahlen und war diese politik von
erfolg gekrönt nun begrüßt ja aber
erfolg war mit hohen politischen kosten
verbunden die usa mussten nicht nur
angesichts der offensichtlichen
ermordung des journalisten durch
saudische agenten beide augen fest
zudrücken nein sie wurden auch zu
komplizen in jenem krieg in dem es hieß
die von ihnen geliefert was nicht immer
astreinen menschenrechtskonform zum
einsatz brachten
und als wäre das noch nicht genug
mussten die usa auch militärisch
intervenieren als öltanker in radis und
audis in der straße fort muss unter
beschuss gerät
das alles waren jedoch nicht die
schwersten opfer die trump seine
verbündeten liefern musste und was essen
bleibt sein verrat an den kurden
langjährigen und verlässlichen
verbündeten der usa
er lieferte sie einem anderen weitaus
weniger verlässlichen aber umso
mächtigeren us-verbündeten ans messer
doors türkei nicht der talks unterm
strich hat trump im nahen osten einer
bilanz vorzuweisen
die so positiv ist wie die kaum eines
seiner amtsvorgänger
denn ein bestimmter historischer erfolg
in der region stellt alle seine
fehlgriffe in den schatten und fragst
dich sofort die rede ist natürlich vom
friedensabkommen zwischen israel und den
arabischen ländern
dieser historische frieden wird das
gesicht der region und vielleicht der
ganzen welt auf lange zeit nachhaltig
gut maßgeblich verändert und zwar einen
deutlich positiven was weißt du hätte
dieses meisterstück irgendein anderer us
präsident auch hinbekommen obama oder
gar hillary clinton schreibt uns doch
eine meinung dazu ganz stellen die
kommentare und so interessiert es wird
dich und dann ist da noch diese sache
auf der anderen seite des pazifiks nein
nicht der nordkoreanische atom zwerg es
geht um den handelskrieg china trump hat
keine militärische allianz gegen china
organisiert um sie unter kontrolle zu
halten
stattdessen hatte ein angriff mit der
macht des dollars gestartet aber das
ging wie wir schon in einem anderen
video platzieren konnten er in die hose
trump hat im grunde nicht viel erreichen
können das ganze hat den us interessen
eher geschadet in washington hat in
diesem konflikt ein sehr wichtiges
behandlungsmittel gegenüber peking
verloren
[Musik]
die sphinx angst vor sanktionen und ein
handelskrieg darf nicht vergessen dass
wir hier von einem herrscher reden der
sogar angst vor wie nächste tour hat
oder was meinst du wie sind diese
comicfigur in ganz china verboten ist
ohne diesen handelskrieg hätte sich
peking eventuell nie getraut vorkommen
zu vereinnahmen und gedichte
unterdrücken was ich damit meine
okay das ist nicht mal kurz erklären
washington hat jedes mal wenn china aus
der reihe tanzte mit sanktionen gedroht
und das hat eigentlich immer gut
funktioniert denn peking musste nie
genau welche konsequenzen die
installationen eigentlich haben würden
und sie hatten er angst davor wollten
über kein großes risiko eingehen
nun aber da kommt diese drohungen wahr
gemacht hat haben sie ihren schrecken
verloren nur so konnte man in peking
feststellen ob und wie immer sanktionen
zu bewältigen sind trump hat also das
pulver der usa gegen china verschossen
ohne den feind wirklich zutreffen oder
washington hat nicht doch hongkong im
stich gelassen
sie hatten auch keine antwort auf die
daraufhin eine aggressive
expansionspolitik roters und das bekommt
nun auch taiwan zu spüren das land ist
immer größeren drohungen und immer
stärkeren druck aus peking ausgesetzt
und wo er ist geradeaus schlagwort
taiwan gefallen ist ursprünglich waren
ein teil der republik jeder und wurde
zum zufluchtsort der offiziellen
chinesischen regierung fiel musste diese
vor den kommunisten mao tse tungs
aufgrund dessen dass dem kommunistischen
regime in peking
da waren ein gewaltiger dorn im auge
denn eigentlich befindet sich die
legitime regierung als china sie hat bis
zum heutigen tag in textil aufteilbar
mehr über diese spannende geschichte und
die sie ausgeben könnte könnt ihr in
anderen video von uns erfahren wenn ihr
jetzt auf den link oben links klickt
aber der mit abstand größte viel schlag
von james amerikas politik ereignete
sich erst vor kurzem china unterzeichnet
gewaltiges asien-pazifik handelsabkommen
mit 14 ländern
teil dieses abkommen sind nicht nur
jenes zehn länder der südostasiatischen
asien gruppe wie zum beispiel thailand
und indonesien viel beunruhigender sind
die unterzeichner als mit dem korea
japan australien und neuseeland also
alles traditionelle verbündete der usa
in der pazifikregion für die regierung
samt bedeutete dies eine niederlage auf
der ganzen linie
denn auch wenn er nicht mehr auf
multilateralismus setzte diese länder
taten ist trotzdem wartet china hat mehr
und mehr einfluss auf internationaler
ebene und auch mehr gewicht
internationalen institutionen gut zu
erkennen zum beispiel in der bhu immer
wenn sich washington zurück sieht recht
peking stellt vor um das vakuum zu
füllen
auch hier haben wir bereits ein schönes
video dazu gemacht so jetzt ist so also
was beiden damit meinte das ist
allerhöchste zeit für amerikas comeback
auf die weltbühne sei was aber wird
dieses comeback mit sich bringen muss
politik hatte ja nicht nur
schattenseiten sondern vor allem auch
lichtblicke keine neuen kriege und der
stabilste frieden im nahen osten seit
langem ist es damit nun vorbei fährt
beiden die amerikanische
kriegsmaschinerie wieder hochkommt das
hässliche antlitz des amerikanischen
imperialismus wieder zum vorschein
the american comeback ist der erste us
präsident der letzten 30 jahre mit
tiefgreifender außenpolitische erfahrung
er war 34 jahre lang mitglied des
außenpolitischen ausschusses des
us-senats und acht jahre vizepräsident
unter obama er ist ein überzeugter
anhänger des multilateralismus und hat
ganz klare vorstellungen deshalb hat er
auch nichts anders als obama die
schlüsselposition der us außenpolitik
mit typischen mit promis wie hillary
clinton und john terry besetzt denn
entgegen dass dazu hat bei einem seiner
langjährigen vertrauten dem nie was
gehört das auserkorene blinke er hat
ihnen mit einer mission der allerhöchste
priorität betraut das vertrauen der von
donald jones verschmähten verbündeten
wieder zu gewinnen
krems trump hat die politlandschaft
verändert sie ist zu america first
geworden was amerika alleine bedeutet
die befinden uns in einer position in
der unser allianzen aussagen sind
die frage ist aber ob der student ist
überhaupt schaffen kann
die brannte erde wieder urbar zu machen
denn im falle des großen asiatisch
pazifischen handelsabkommen ist hat
china einfach tatsachen geschaffen und
seine position etabliert für die usa
wird es extrem schwierig werden ihre
bedingungen gegen die unerbittliche
normative kraft des faktischen
durchzusetzen
beide hat durch auch schon eine idee mit
welche herangehensweise er diese
verzwickte situation lösen könnte er
will die usa die des unangefochtenen
anführer der restlichen welt machen
diese soll sich dann mit amerika an
ihrer spitze geschlossen an den
verhandlungstisch mit peking setzen denn
sowohl beiden als auch blinken glauben
dass washington mit der unterstützung
seiner verbündeten zu picken sagen kann
china hinter uns stehen 60 prozent des
weltweiten bip nicht nur die führung 20
usa wir ziehen jetzt an einem strang und
lassen die jetzt nicht mehr alles
durchgehen beides theorie nacht soll es
so möglich sein china ein wenig respekt
gegenüber den spielregeln des
internationalen handels abzuverlangen
spielregeln wie zum beispiel den schutz
geistigen ein spiel regeln wie zb den
schutz geistigen eigentums und die
eindämmung unlauteren wettbewerbs durch
staatliche unterstützung privater
unternehmen wie zum beispiel recht wie
du siehst bedeutet machtwechsel im
weißen haus also nicht eine kehrtwende
weg von chance politik die die usa sehen
in china heute in ganz anderem licht als
noch vor zehn jahren
die demokraten waren damals davon
überzeugt dass chinas wirtschaftskraft
und schließlich auch zu reformen und
mittel china tour fühlen würden wenn
china war seit der zeit vor dem shopping
versöhnungspolitik einer der größten
nutznießer der pax americana die durch
die usa geforderte politische stabilität
und globale handelsbeziehungen haben dem
land entscheidend dabei geholfen zur
wirtschaftlichen weltmacht aufzusteigen
das problem die demokratische rechnung
der amerikaner gegen ganz und gar nicht
auf und politischen reformen hin zu mehr
freiheit und demokratie ist das
kommunistische regime weiter entfernt
denn je
das im gegenteil im zuge der korona
pandemie dreht peking und den spieß um
den anstalt selbst freiheit zu
importieren exportiert es nun die
eigenen werte der unfreiheit und
methoden der unterdrückung entrechtung
und totalität in alle welt autokratie
die willkürliche einschränkung von
bürgerrechten zensur ja sogar die fälle
des social scoring all das gefällt auch
im westen immer mehr menschen oder wird
von ihnen zumindest hingenommen und die
politik immer nach noch mehr macht
rechts und ergreift die gelegenheit
natürlich beim schopf und das alles
unter dem deckmantel des gemeinwohls und
fortschritt es ist eine bittere wahrheit
durch krone ist die ganze welt mehr wie
china geworden und was denn beiden wird
diese entwicklung nicht so schnell
rückgängig machen was er jedoch bereits
vor gericht gemacht hat ist er von
komplizierte rückzug der usa aus der
weltgesundheitsorganisation peru und aus
den pariser klimaabkommen was sich also
radikal ändern wird ist die position der
vereinigten staaten in internationalen
institutionen entscheiden will in diesem
von trump verlassen strategischen
stellen auch china die stirn bietet
seine harte linie in sachen
menschenrechte hongkong taiwan und auch
in der von frank begonnene
neuausrichtung der handelsbeziehungen
macht er in einem ersten telefonat mit
präsident jean ping sehr deutlich beiden
catchy persönlich sehr gut denn beide
haben sich früher als vizepräsident in
ihrer länder aus getroffen und schiess
reaktion auf biden harte haltung stil
denn auch sehr mäßig und persönlich
ausschließlich hatte er gehofft mit den
machtwechsel in washington würde er mit
der leichteres spiel haben ja
pustekuchen beiden setzt den druck auf
china den shop aufgebaut hatte ford und
es sieht ganz danach aus dass er durch
eine geschickte bündnis politik noch
einen draufsetzen selbst während er
nämlich gleich nach seinem amtsantritt
von tropen straffälligen die eu sofort
aufhob tastete er die gegend china nicht
an er ließ die sensation gegen
verweigerer auch auf dessen zulieferer
ausweiten und baute blitzschnell er ist
das großes bündnis geht hinauf zwischen
indien japan australien und den usa
diese allianz die sich der kurs nennt
und sich als demokratisches gegengewicht
zum totalitären china sieht koordiniert
nun fleißig im rahmen virtueller
gipfeltreffen der regierungschefs eine
gemeinsame politik um chinas
expansionismus und interessen muss im
zaum zu halten
und das war nicht alles der beiden ließ
auch zwei flugzeugträger angriff kommen
inzwischen mehr stationären und
entsandte weitere kriegsschiffe in die
nähe der chinesischen paracelsus um dort
zusammen mit ai waren belegt er manöver
abzuhalten ein deutliches signal nach
peking wohin die reise ab jetzt gehen
wird auch auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz machte beiden
deutlich dass er die usa wieder zu ihrer
starten führungsrolle innerhalb der nato
zurück bringen wird hierzu machte er
deutlich dass die übrigen mitglieder der
nato nun mit einem militärische
wesentlich aktiveren amerika zählen
könnten mit allen konsequenzen die diese
mit sich reden
biden will mehr hilfe anbieten dafür
aber den ton angeben erdogan wird es
also schwerhaben ihnen hatte beiden
schon vor seiner wahl als autokraten
bezeichnet und die türkische opposition
aufgefordert den endlich zu ersetzen
natürlich nicht durch einen putsch
sondern im rahmen demokratischer wahlen
denn alle nato partner müssen nun auf
linie gebracht werden schließlich
drückte sich biden auch noch putin vor
und nimmt dabei wahrlich kein blatt vor
dem mund sondern kann es offenbar ganz
gezielt auf eine eskalation abgesehen
der so unverblümt wie biden hat wohl
seit dem ende der sowjetunion noch kein
us präsident seinen russischen
counterpart angegriffen
er hält putin hochoffiziell für einen
hat er durch fest kaltblütigen mörder
mehr noch rot rote wladimir
wladimirowitsch persönlich damit er
werde für all seine machenschaften wie
auch die einmischung in die us wahlen
noch einen preis bezahlen müssen
arbeitet beiden also schon hintergrund
an plänen für einen regime change in
moskau
das virtual politik in diesem jahr zum
zweiten mal sein schönes intro
austauschen müssen
russland jedenfalls versucht das ganze
eher herunter zu spielen und zu
deeskalieren
herr putin etwa schon die hosen
gestrichen voll oder ist einfach nur ein
weißer gemäßigter diplomat der weiß dass
russland bei einer konfrontation mit den
usa nur verlieren kann
erinnert ihr euch noch anfangs
sanktionen gegen die russische erdgas
pipeline nord stream 2 wir haben darüber
auch ein video gemacht nun der bereits
erwähnte neue außenminister und beides
enger vertrauter internet blinken macht
er am vorabend dann möchte klar dass
washington entschlossen sei die
fertigstellung der pipeline zu starten
klicken zufolge würde sie im putin
regime ermöglichen russlands
energieressourcen weiter als etwas
verein zu dessen um politischen druck in
ganz europa auszuüben und deswegen
bereitet die regierung beiden auch schon
neue sanktionen gegen unternehmen vor
die an dem projekt nord stream 2
beteiligt sind
ganz egal ob die deutsche regierung
davon begeistert ist oder nicht denn
biden forderte europa müsse sich wieder
strikt an den vorgaben aus washington
ausrichten um sich sowohl gegen die
unterwanderung der eu nato durch den
kreml zu stellen als auch sich gemeinsam
auf einen langfristigen strategischen
wettbewerb mit china vorzubereiten denn
mclaren agro können ja jetzt nicht mehr
auf ihre haut drauf mit trump schimpfen
und bekräftigten denn auch schnell ihre
bedingungslose unterstützung des
multilateralismus das heißt der
wiederhergestellten pax americana
denn mit der demokratischen mehrheit in
beiden häusern des parlaments setzt
beiden die aixtron regalen und
ungebremst um diplomatisch in form von
bündnissen in der therapie von
aufrüstung und wirtschaftlich in form
von sanktionen und der notenpresse ja
genau du hast dich verhört einer seiner
mächtigsten waffen ist das kürzlich
aufgesetzte mega konjunkturprogramm in
den die us regierung fast sage und
schreibe zwei billionen dollar
verballert damit soll die us-wirtschaft
im jahr 2021 schneller wachsen als die
china etwas was hat ihnen ja hannes 176
mehr passiert ist da wird shipping ganz
schön dumm aus der wäsche gucken denn er
hat den chinesen so versprochen bis 2028
die usa als wirtschaftsmacht nummer eins
abzulösen
daraus davor so schnell nichts vor allem
wenn sie das katastrophale demografie in
ein paar jahren ihre volle wirkung
entfalten wird also was meint ihr wird
amerika und der beiden also wieder so
einer imperialen großmacht wird er zu
einem höflichen jump aber plus bomben
werden wir in den nachrichten bald
wieder von neuen kriegen mit ms
beteiligung hören und grundsätzlich ist
die pax americana eine gute sache für
unsere welt und unsere freiheitliche
grundordnung schreibt uns eure meinung
in die kommentare unter diesem video
denn immer sind wir auch diese schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video fallen auch etwas gebracht hat was
ja gibt uns bitte ein kleines like und
unterstützt uns in denen dieses video
mit euren freunden teilt was gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]